But we're going to start with Democrats
putting a great big exclamation
point on the 2022 midterm season
and projecting incumbent Senator
Raphael Warnock has defeated Trump picked
Republican challenger Herschel Walker.
In Georgia's runoff election.
President Joe Biden
calling Warnock to congratulate him,
tweeting this as well.
Tonight,
Georgia voters
stood up for democracy, for our democracy
and reject it.
Ultra MAGA ism
or not
got emotional
as he thanked his supporters
My roots,
like the roots of those oak trees,
go deep down into the soil of Savannah
and Waycross
and Scriven County in Berks County.
I am Georgia
Well, Herschel Walker
was quick to concede, sort of
you have to really listen to the language
in what he said.
He didn't really talk about his opponent.
Just think to supporters
vowing to never stop fighting
for the people of Georgia.
There's no excuses in life.
And I'm not going to make an excuse now
because we put up one heck of a fight.
And I think that's what
that's what we got to do
because this is much bigger.
This is much bigger than Herschel Walker.
So, look,
you guys don't want to see me
this morning.
This is who you want to see.
John Berman, the guy the guy of the hour.
The man of the hour.
Besides Raphael Warnock,
I should say at the magic wall,
everyone wants to know what happened.
You've got the numbers.
You have the evidence. So take it away.
Well, here's the margin.
First of all, Raphael Warnock
with a 95,000 vote margin, about 2.8%.
Compare that to just one month ago.
The general election
was only one month ago.
You can see
Warnock led by 0.9% and 37,000 votes.
So he's grown that lead.
Where has he done it?
Let's look at where Warnock overperformed
one month ago.
Almost everywhere, right?
Almost every county here is lit up.
So let's look at it a different way.
Where did Herschel Walker
underperform in? This is telling.
Look at this.
Because what
all these areas have in common.
You have the Atlanta area,
the urban and suburban area.
They're right around Columbus,
right around Augusta,
right around Savannah.
While these areas have in common, it's
where the large population centers are.
The bigger the circle,
the more the population,
all the big circles really
in those areas
where Herschel Walker underperformed.
And what's interesting
and I think as you talk to Republicans
over the course of the morning,
what you'll find,
the areas
they're most concerned about,
the suburban areas around Atlanta.
Take Gwinnett County, for instance.
You can see
Raphael Warnock won Gwinnett County.
What's the math there by about plus 25.
Let's do D-plus.
25 in Gwinnett County.
That's a big margin,
especially when you're talking
about hundreds of thousands of votes
just two years ago.
That margin was D-plus.
21. Okay.
And the presidential election,
which is right around
that time it was D plus 18.
Go back to the presidential election
in 2016.
Hillary Clinton.
It's D-plus See a trend there.
I do.
It's growing
or getting smaller depending
how you look at it in 2012.
Mitt Romney won Gwinnett County
ten years ago.
You went from Republicans
winning that county
by what nine points almost to now
you have a Democrat winning it
by 25 points.
That's a remarkable turnaround.
And again these are the suburban areas.
And you lived there for a time, Don.
You know, it's not just urban Atlanta.
It's East
growing suburban areas that are booming
where Democrats are gaining a population
and gaining in popularity areas
that are more diverse. Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, but listen,
that's why, you know,
people say, well,
Georgia is a pink state,
a purple or whatever it is.
But I mean, look at all the red there.
I still consider
Georgia to be a red state.
That's just my personal opinion.
The cities
and the surrounding suburbs, blue.
But I mean,
if you look at the vast
majority, at least land wise, area wise,
it's still a pretty red state.
It is. But geography doesn't vote.
Right? Right. Right.
So you're looking at all
the red counties.
I'll put that up again
where Walker outperformed Walker.
Geography votes, though,
in national elections.
Yeah. Yeah.
Well, with the Electoral College
it has a little bit of advantage.
But you look here.
Look, Herschel Walker
did better in Dade County
than he did one month ago.
But you can see you're only talking about
5000 votes. Yes.
He did better.
He got more percent,
two more percent than he did
one month ago.
But you're dealing with 5000 votes.
And you compare that to Don,
you compare it to Fulton County.
Again,
you're talking about several hundred
thousand votes.
DeKalb County, several
hundred thousand votes.
It's where the people live
right now,
and particularly in suburban areas
that used to be Republican strongholds.
Cobb County right here,
this is Newt
Gingrich lived here,
and now it's voting for Democrats by now
points.
Wow.
Now, that is a fun fact, so to speak.
John Berman, always a pleasure.
Thank you, sir.
Gentlemen, great seeing you said it.
Thanks, Don and John.
And as you know,
we're looking at those numbers.
Let's
bring in the Atlanta Journal-Constitution
political reporter Patricia Murphy
to talk about this.
One of the things
we were watching last night
were how these candidates fared in
November versus how they did last night.
As John was just highlighting
there, we're not doing much better
in those metro Atlanta areas. We're not.
Walker did okay
in some of the ruby red areas.
The rural parts of the state.
But what were your biggest takeaways
of what changed from just a month ago
to this runoff election?
So as John Berman
laid out really, really well,
Herschel Walker
had one job to do last night,
and that was to expand
his lead in those rural areas,
to really start to run up his numbers
and to catch up with where Brian Kemp
had been just a month ago.
Herschel Walker didn't do that.
He even shrank
in some of those rural areas.
He grew his numbers in some cases,
but only by one or 2%.
He needed to grow that by five or 6%.
And so we didn't see him do that.
And at the same time, Raphael Warnock
did expand
his lead
in the big metro
areas around Savannah, Augusta, Columbus,
Atlanta, of course.
And so
they both
were dealing with a change in enthusiasm.
It really felt
like Herschel
Walker's enthusiasm for his candidacy
really fell off almost a cliff.
You could feel it in the state
and you could feel Raphael Warnock
and the Democrats say to themselves,
okay,
this this party just lost
eight statewide elections in November.
We have one more chance to win statewide.
And that was Raphael Warnock.
He also ran a totally different campaign
from Herschel Walker
reached out to those moderate
and independent voters.
And he was everywhere,
all across the state
throughout the runoff.
And Herschel Walker
really kept
a very limited schedule,
didn't get back out to the areas
he hit before.
And so you just saw that
in the numbers last night.
And he actually took
five days off the campaign trail.
And that's been a source of frustration
that I've heard from
from some people in Walker's campaign.
He came out the last night and conceded
and his campaign made clear, yes,
that was a concession speech.
Yes.
Because in his speech
he didn't say I called Raphael Warnock.
He didn't say that.
He didn't say I officially concede,
but he wasn't saying that he won.
He did call himself and his supporters
winners that really just
we we won because we tried
and we did our best.
But afterward, his staff did
tell reporters that was a concession.
This is there's going to be no attempt
to challenge these results.
And I think it's something
that the state
really needed to see from Republicans.
This is the first time
that we've had a Democrat win
statewide since the last elections.
And Herschel Walker
coming out and conceding
and sort of stepping off the stage.
I think that's something
that the state needed to see.
And I think that's something that he did
well last night.
And, you know, Georgia so well,
what John and
I were just talking about there is
what does this mean for the state?
Does it mean it's more of a purple state?
But as you noted,
you Republicans won every every election
on the ticket statewide
except for Herschel Walker's seat.
And so what's your sense?
Was it
was it a more about
a reflection of the state or was it
just candidate quality?
I think it's both.
I mean, you can't ignore
the candidate quality of Herschel Walker
during the runoff period.
He also had
his major gaffe about vampires
versus werewolves.
There were more
accusations of abuse against him
that came out as well.
So he had a really bad runoff campaign
after a really tough general election.
Campaign as well for him,
just not a great candidate.
However, what we see in Georgia right now
is that this is a true
battleground state.
A candidate from either party can win,
and that's a place that Georgia hasn't
been in decades. It has.
I can't remember the last time
somebody could say, I'm
going to run statewide.
I'm a Democrat, I'm a Republican,
and there are reasons
for those national parties
to get behind them
because they've all got
a really good shot at winning this state.
It's winnable right now for both parties.